量子コンピューティング実践編へようこそ。このエピソードでは、最初の、そしてしばしば最も
困難なステップ、つまり量子プログラムを定義する際に一般的な問題をquantum computerで動作できるcircuitにマッピングすることに焦点を当てる。
このステップは、特定の計算上の問題から始めるユーザーが
その問題をquantum computerが理解できるように変換する方法を説明している。
このシリーズの以前のレッスン、レッスン2と3では、マッピングステージがQiskit patternsフレームワークの4つのステップのうちの最初のステップであることを議論した。
これらのレッスンから、私たちの目標が計算上の問題をコスト関数や期待値に変換または
書き換えることだったことを覚えているかもしれない。
それをquantum computerを使って評価できるようにするためだ。
レッスン3では、max cut問題という具体的な例を1つ議論した。
これは計算上困難であり、組み合わせ最適化においてよく見られる問題だ。
その例では、最初のグラフを量子ネイティブな問題に変換するためにいくつかのステップを経た。
グラフ内の最大カット数を求める問題をコスト関数に変換し、そのコスト
関数をHamiltonianとして書き直し、基底状態が
max cutに対応する試行量子状態を準備した。最後に、試行量子状態を表すquantum circuitを構築し、
状態が時間とともに発展できるように特定のgateを追加した。このステップの連なりが私たちが
マッピングと呼ぶものだ。そして大まかに言えば、この手順は量子化学などの多くの他のアプリケーションに一般的に適用できる。
量子シミュレーションにもだ。さて、マッピングが困難であることは否定できない事実だ。
すべての問題に対応する万能な戦略はないため、威圧的に感じることもある。今日は
異なる問題のいくつかの代表的な例を紹介し、それぞれの場合にどのようにマッピングされたかを説明する。
Max Cutで使用されたようなグラフ問題について学んだことを簡単に振り返り、残りの講義では
生物学における分子構造問題、電子
構造問題in chemistry、高エネルギー物理学における量子場理論のシミュレーションなど、自然界に現れる問題のマッピング方法に焦点を当てる。
しかし、このエピソードのほとんどの時間を文献からの問題例を見ることに費やす前に、
問題をマッピングする際に達成したいこと、考慮すべきことについて高レベルの概観を伝えたい。
quantum circuitに変換する必要があるどんな種類の計算問題にも考慮すべきことがいくつかある。
第一に、問題を実行可能にするために単純化する必要があるかもしれない。これはほとんどの科学的な
分野で一般的なことだ。量子コンピューティングに特有のことではない。「球形の牛を仮定する」という表現を聞いたことがあれば、
それはシステムをあるがままに正確に記述することがしばしば難しいという事実を示唆している。しかし
その代わりに、役立つ解決策につながり得る合理的な単純化を行うことができる。
量子コンピューティングでこれを行う方法の例としては、hardware効率の良いansatzを選んだり、circuit sizeやcircuit depthを制限したりすること、複雑な時間発展を打ち切ること、または
量子状態の最終エネルギーにほとんど寄与しないHamiltonian項を無視することなどがある。
（省略）
次に伝えたいことは、quantum computerが理解できるような形で問題を書くことを考える必要があるということだ。
多くの場合、それは次の3つの質問をすることを含む。1つ目、私たちのqubitは
このモデルで何を表すのか？2つ目、問題は連続的か？quantum computerはデジタルなので、
問題を離散化する方法を見つける必要がある。そして3つ目、最後に、問題のトポロジーはhardwareのトポロジーと一致するか？
もし一致するなら素晴らしい。しかし一致しない場合は、うまく機能させるためのトリックを実装する必要があるかもしれない。では
この最初の質問に答えよう。特に新しい概念としてのマッピングを理解する際の困難の核心にあると私が思うことだ。
qubitは何を表せるのか？
qubitは多くのものを表すために使用できる。私の意見では最初で最も単純なのは、グラフ上のノードだ。グラフは
多くの異なる種類の数学的問題において接続性を示すために使用される。そしてノードはネットワーク内の点を表す基本的な要素だ。
ネットワーク全体が何を表すかによって、それは都市、人、または
格子内の強磁性体である可能性がある。qubitはbosonやfermionを表すためにも使用できる。ただしここで注意したいのは、
1つのqubitが1つのbosonや1つのfermionと正確に等しいわけではないということだ。
それよりも少し複雑で、すぐに詳しく説明するが、一般的に言えば、ある統計に従うスピンの連鎖は
qubitアーキテクチャに容易に変換できるものだ。
さて、もう少し複雑な例に入っていく。これらのモデルでは、もはや
1つのqubitという観点で話すことは意味をなさない。
代わりに、物理的なものを構成するためにそれらのグループが必要だ。例えば、
heavy hexagonalトポロジー上に表現されたqubitのグループは、アミノ酸の幾何学的な位置を表すために使用できる。
またはポリマー鎖を表すためにも使用できる。もう1つの例は高エネルギー物理学モデルにおけるhadron散乱のシミュレーションで、
hadronicウェーブパケットの時間発展をシミュレートすることで実行できる。この場合、
qubitのレジスタは量子場の異なる状態をエンコードするために使用できる。その場の真空状態や
この真空の上に伝播するウェーブパケットを表すことができる。
また、問題をquantum computerにマッピングすることには明確なステップがあることも指摘しておきたい。1つ目は状態を
qubitとcircuitにマッピングすること、2つ目はコスト関数または量子観測量と演算子の期待値を
マッピングすることだ。これらが具体的な例でどのように扱われるかを見ていく。しかし
この時点では、私たちが直面している課題について十分に抽象的に話してきた。
では今、これらの例を詳しく見ていこう。
最初の例から始めよう。私の意見では、最も簡単なマッピング問題の1つは、すでに
ある程度詳しく取り上げたmax cutの例だ。その問題では、1つのqubitが
グラフ上の1つのノードに等しい。グラフ上のノードを使うのは非常に直感的で、それは
多くのアプリケーションに対応しているから好都合だ。互いに繋がった一連のノードをモデル化したい場合、
グループ分けがゼロか1か、あるいはセットに含まれるか含まれないかのような二値であれば、
これらのノードをビットやqubitに単純かつ自然にマッピングできる。
この例では、エピソード3で100 qubitにスケールアップした例でさえ、グラフの接続性は
すでに超伝導ハードウェアのトポロジーと一致していた。だからそちらも気にする必要がなかった。でも、それが常にそうとは限らない。
これまで紹介した例よりも複雑または接続されたグラフがある場合は、
swap gateを実装する必要が出てくる。ただしこれは実際にはQiskit patternsの第二ステップ、つまり
transpilerに関するステップで処理される。max cut問題がこれほど便利な理由のもう一つは、
QUBO定式化を使ったHamiltonianとしてコスト関数を表現する方法がすでにわかっているからだ。
量子コンピューティングと変分量子アルゴリズムにおいて、Hamiltonianコスト関数とは、
問題の最適解をHamiltonianの基底状態にエンコードする関数だ。
コストHamiltonianを構築するために、Qiskitのsparse poly opクラスを使ってグラフの
接続性を指定でき、量子演算子へのマッピング段階はこれで完了する。そして量子circuitは
単純にQAOA ansatzだった。もしピンとこなければ、エピソード3に戻って確認してほしい。そこでは
もっと詳しく説明している。では、難易度を少しだけ上げてみよう。次に見ていくのは、
「resource efficient quantum algorithm for protein folding」という論文でモデル化された例だ。著者は
IBMとニューサウスウェールズ大学との共同研究だ。少し生化学の背景を説明すると、タンパク質は
アミノ酸の長い鎖で構成された高分子だ。これらの長い鎖は
広範な生物学的機能を発揮する複雑な構造に折り畳まれる。
三次元空間でのタンパク質構造の決定と、
構造と機能の関係の理解は、今日の生化学における最も困難な問題の一つだ。
タンパク質はアミノ酸同士の相互作用によって有用な構造に折り畳まれる。
構造がねじれて折り畳まれると、鎖上で互いに遠い位置にあるアミノ酸が隣り合わせになる
こともあり、強く相互作用することがある。最終的にエネルギーを最小化する構造を予測したいなら、これらのアミノ酸間の
相互作用をすべて記述するHamiltonianが必要だ。ここではアミノ酸鎖に焦点を当てて、
量子コンピュータ上でどうモデル化できるか、そしてアミノ酸間距離をどう求めるかを見ていく。
相互作用エネルギーの計算のためだ。
これにより、量子コンピュータ上でシミュレートするためのHamiltonianに必要な
すべての寄与を集めることができる。実際のタンパク質では、アミノ酸は連続した可能な位置を占めることができる。
ただし、ここでは簡略化を使って、各アミノ酸が
格子上の点を占める格子モデルに制限する。ここでは著者たちは四面体格子を使用した。
ここで注意点として、max cut問題のようにノード自体ではなく、エッジの方向をエンコードしている。
各qubitは四面体格子上の一ステップの経路を表す。隣接するサイトは
格子内での向きの違いにより、この図ではAまたはBとラベル付けされている。
タンパク質鎖はこの格子上の一連のターンまたは方向として表現される。
アミノ酸間の各ターンは4つの方向のいずれかを取ることができ、
それは四面体のエッジに対応する。
この4つの可能なターンは4つのqubitを使ってエンコードされる。
少し複雑に聞こえるかもしれない。だからもう少し詳しく見てみよう。
最初のアミノ酸を四面体格子上のこの点に置いてみよう。最初の
アミノ酸から2番目のアミノ酸への方向は任意だ。なぜならシステムは常に回転させて、そのエッジを
好きな方向に向けることができるからだ。だから2番目のアミノ酸をここに置こう。少し
わかりにくいが、2番目から3番目への経路も実は任意だ。3つの選択肢はどれも
約109.5°の角度を持つ2つのエッジを持つ結果になる。
この2番目のエッジを選ぶことは、単に空間内でのタンパク質の向きを決めるだけだ。だから一般性を失うことなく、
最初のターンを単に0 0 1および0 0 1
0と選べる。これらの簡略化により、アミノ酸鎖の配置はこの式で単純に表される。
ここまでで四面体のエッジをqubitにマッピングし、量子circuitはansatzになる。次に
問題のエネルギーをHamiltonianにエンコードする方法を考える必要がある。その基底状態が最適な
折り畳みパターンを与えるようにするためだ。さて、任意の配置に対して、
アミノ酸同士の相互作用による関連エネルギーが存在する。これらの相互作用は2つのアミノ酸が
互いに近い時に最も強くなる。明らかに、鎖のバックボーン上で隣接するアミノ酸は常に相互作用するが、
タンパク質がねじれて折り畳まれることで、他のアミノ酸ペアも
相互作用することができる。例えば10番と20番のアミノ酸は、
タンパク質が折り畳まれた後に隣接サイトに位置することがある。互いに近くなったアミノ酸は強い
相互作用を持ち折り畳みプロセスを駆動するが、必ずしも互いに近いインデックスを持つとは
限らない。だから、配置qubit上にエンコードされた情報を使って、アミノ酸IとJの間の
距離Dを記述する式が必要だ。そうすれば
その距離を使ってどれくらい強く相互作用しているかがわかる。これは少し複雑だが、
うまいトリックがあるので付き合ってほしい。まず、f sub a of iという関数を導入しよう。これはエッジaが
アミノ酸iのターンで使われているかどうかを示す。ここでaは任意の値を取り得る。
上記の配置コーディングを踏まえた4つの可能な方向のうちの1つだ。これらの関数を定義した上で、
AとBの格子上でラベル付きターンの数の差を
インデックスIからJまでデルタNとして定義できる。なぜそうするかって？実は
四面体格子には非常に便利な性質がある。ここのアミノ酸に注目しよう。どれでも構わないが、
Eアミノ酸と呼ぶことにしよう。Jアミノ酸がどれだけ離れているかを知りたい。わかっているのは
バックボーンが進む辺だけだ。Iから始めて、特定の辺タイプ
（これをaと呼ぶ）に沿ってこのA格子点から
中心から外へ出た一歩は、B格子点からのaに沿った
一歩によってちょうど逆向きで打ち消される。つまり、任意のA格子点から辺Aに沿って進めば
バックボーンはEアミノ酸から遠ざかり、B格子点から辺タイプAに沿えば
戻ってくる。よって2つのアミノ酸IとJの間の辺
タイプAにおける距離は、Aに沿った
A格子点とB格子点からのステップの差に依存する。AとBはタンパク質
バックボーン中で必ず交互に現れるので、これは(-1)のK乗の項で表される。この議論は他の辺タイプにも
適用できる。つまり四面体格子ステップにおけるアミノ酸間の距離は、最終的にこの
式で計算できる。しかし、アミノ酸間の総距離を表すこの長い式からどうやってHamiltonianを得るのか？実は
四面体格子ステップにおけるこれらの距離とユークリッド
距離の間には一対一の対応がある。いくつかの式はすでに計算済みだ。
これらの距離は配置のエネルギー計算に使える。
目的に応じて、相互作用するとみなすカットオフ距離を設定したり、
より複雑な方法を使ったりすることもある。気づきにくいかもしれないが、実はこれでマッピング
段階は完了だ。qubitの状態がターンを示し、ターンの集合が
任意のアミノ酸ペア間の距離を決定する。様々な種類のアミノ酸の
ペアには異なる相互作用があり、引力的なものも斥力的なものもある。配置と距離を使って
既知のアミノ酸相互作用がオンかオフかを判断するだけなら、
その強さはよく知られている。私が知っているわけじゃないが、こういう表で調べられる。まとめると、
この例ではqubitが格子上の位置を示すために使われ、それらが合わさってアミノ酸の鎖を形成する。
それらの曲がり方や折り畳み方をシミュレートすることで、医療研究でより良い成果が得られることを期待できる。さて、
このHamiltonianのいくつかの項の計算は省略した。この問題に特有のものだったからだ。一方、格子上の
方向の定義はより一般的に適用できる。
一般的なHamiltonianが得られたら、それをPauli演算子に変換したくなるはずだ。Pauli演算子は
量子コンピュータ固有のものだ。次はそれを説明する。
続けよう。では、素粒子系をPauli演算子に変換する方法を探っていこう。素粒子は
2つのカテゴリに分けられる。ボゾンとフェルミオンだ。
光子やヒッグス粒子のようなボゾンはある統計的規則に従い、電子やニュートリノのようなフェルミオンはまた別の規則に従う。
両者の主な違いは、ボゾンは同じ状態を占有できることだ。何個の
ボゾンが基底状態や他の励起状態にいても制限はない。一方フェルミオンは利己的で、
すべての粒子が独自の量子状態を持つことを要求する。ボゾンは整数スピンを持ち、フェルミオンは半整数
スピンを持つ。スピン1/2の電子や、より特殊なスピン3/2の粒子のようにだ。
粒子系を記述するにはエネルギーの記述が必要だ。フェルミオンに注目しよう。C演算子と呼ばれるものを使った
Hamiltonianから始められる。これらは基本的に、系の状態から
フェルミオンを生成または消滅させることに対応する数学的オブジェクトだ。
これらはしばしばφダガーとφと書かれ、第二量子化と呼ばれる
記法を使う。φダガーは状態iにフェルミオンを生成する演算子だ。φは
状態iのフェルミオンを消滅させる演算子だ。しかし量子コンピュータは通常qubit
基底で動作し、フェルミオン系を表現するための特定の規則がある。フェルミオン演算子の
言語では本質的に動作しない。このギャップを埋めるために、第二量子化記法をPauli演算子にマッピングする必要があり、
Pauli演算子は量子gateに自然に対応する。
フェルミオンに対してはいくつかの変換がある。よく使われるのはJordan-Wigner変換だ。
Bravyi-Kitaevおよびパリティマッピングはフェルミオンエンコーディングとしてより最近のものだ。
一方ボゾン演算は、Holstein-Primakoff変換を使うか、Fock状態を
利用可能なボゾンモードのサブ基底に直接マッピングすることで変換できる。
ボゾンには他の選択肢もある。他のエンコーディングも活発に研究されている。しかし今は
Jordan-Wigner変換だけに注目しよう。
では、各電子を表すのにqubitを1つ割り当てればいいのでは？それはできない。
qubitは区別可能だが、電子は区別できないからだ。例えば、デバイス上の個々のqubitは簡単にラベル付けして識別できるが、
電子の区別不可能性はラベル付けが全くできないことを意味する。実際にラベル付けが必要なのは
特定の電子ではなく、1s、2s、2pのような占有軌道に応じた
演算子だ。つまり実際には特定の電子にラベルを付けるのではなく、1s、
2s、2pのような占有軌道に応じて演算子にラベルを付ける必要がある。そのため各qubitは
分子中の軌道の役割をほぼ担い、占有か非占有かのいずれかになる。
しかしその方法は実際にはもう少し複雑だ。そこでJordan-Wignerマッピングと呼ばれるものを導入して追跡する。
反対称性を確保し、全体のフェルミオン系の正しい統計が守られるようにする。Jordan
Wigner mappingは、軌道とqubitの一対一の対応があるため、概念的にシンプルだ。
par mappingを含む、同様の目的を達成する他のmappingも存在する。
ある状態のparの計算には、複数のqubitを考慮する必要がある。par mappingや他のいくつかでは、
1つのqubitが1つの軌道に対応するという解釈は成り立たない。
それでは、この変換の感覚をつかむために、かなりシンプルな例を一緒に見ていこう。
単一のqubit相互作用 f dagger f を計算したいとしよう。まず、生成演算子と消滅演算子の定義を代入するところから始める。
次に、単位行列 i と 1/4 を括り出して、項をまとめることができる。
見ての通り、交換関係に馴染みのある人には見覚えのある項が残る。ここで括弧内のこの項は
i × x knot と y の交換子に他ならない。そして
括り出した単位行列も忘れないように。
これらはPauli行列に過ぎないことを思い出してほしい。だから交換子はよく知られている。x と y の交換子を
この順番で計算するとシンプルだ。2 i z になる。負の符号を見失わないように気をつければ、これが最終的な
結果になる。最終的に、フェルミオンの表式を量子コンピュータが理解できる
Pauli演算子の言葉で書き直すことに成功した。
Jordan Wigner mappingをQiskitでどう実装するか手短に話そう。mappingや似たような変換がどう機能するかを理解し、
少なくとも一度は実際に計算を追うことが大事だと思うけど、
毎回この計算を手動でやりたいとは思わないだろう。
特に大規模なシステムの場合、Qiskitのsparse poly op関数を活用して
mappingから関連するPauli演算子を簡単に生成できる。最適化されていない
実装ではネストされたループを使い、約20行のコードになる。
コードはここにリンクしておくので、皆さん自由に探ってほしい。大まかな手順は以下の通りだ。
1つ目、sparse poly ops from list関数を使って単位演算子を生成する。
これはmappingするパラメータ空間のサイズに対応する。2つ目、前に示した生成
演算子と消滅演算子の定義に従い、sparse polyops from list関数を使ってx、y、z Pauli
演算子を定義する。これにより、フェルミオンの生成・消滅演算子をqubitスピン演算子にmappingし、フェルミオンの
占有数をqubitの計算基底にエンコードする。3つ目、望ましい
Hamiltonianをpoly基底で生成するため、上記の演算子を対象の軌道に適用する。これは通常、
非相互作用軌道のコアを表す単位行列を生成し、その後で問題に固有の重みをもとに生成
演算子と消滅演算子をactive spaceに適用することに対応する。先ほど述べたように、これはあくまで大まかな説明だ。ただ
コードはそれほど複雑ではないし、他の問題への応用にも自信を持って
取り組めるはずだ。
Jordan Wigner mappingの仕組みを完全に理解した今、もっと複雑なセットアップで実際に動かしてみよう。
このペーパーは前のエピソードでも紹介した、ハドロン動力学に関するものだ。ペーパーを再度詳しく解説するつもりはないけど、
見逃していて気になる人はぜひ前のエピソードをチェックしてほしい。この例では、Jordan Wigner mappingを使って
電場なしのSchwinger modelにおけるL個のlattice siteのHamiltonianを表す。ここでは、
このモデルで1つのqubitが何を表すかを具体的に特定するのはずっと難しい。それは
qubitの集合全体が物理的な意味を持つからだ。この文脈ではwave packetだ。代わりに、
qubitを離散化された空間の断片として大まかに考えることができる。ここでLはlattice volumeであり、各要素つまり
単位セルは2つのqubitで構成される。前のスライドで見たfermion演算子は特定のサイト上の
波動関数の振幅を記述する。
つまりHamiltonianにはこれらのフェルミオンの生成・消滅演算子が含まれている。しかし、このような
Hamiltonianを量子コンピュータで実装するには、フェルミオン演算子ではなくスピン演算子で表現する必要がある。
そこでJordan Wigner変換を使う。Jordan Wigner変換を適用すると、新しい
Hamiltonianはスライド下部のこの式になる。sigma plusはPauli演算子 X + I Y であり、sigma
minus は X - IY だ。この形式でHamiltonianが書けたなら、
mappingの段階の難しい部分は終わりで、Pauli演算子のcircuitに簡単に書き下せる。
まとめると、最近の量子コンピューティング分野で特定のmapping技術がどう使われているかについて4つの例を議論した。
最もシンプルなものから始めて、Jordan Wigner変換をハドロン動力学に適用するところまで進んだ。
これは確かに盛りだくさんだと思う。この内容はとても技術的で、
初めて見る人には圧倒されるかもしれない。良い知らせは、練習に時間をかけるほど
慣れて楽になっていくと約束できることだ。それこそが本質であり、シリーズ全体を
「Quantum Computing in Practice」と名付けた理由でもある。
これはいきなり誰でも習得できるものじゃない。ある程度の勉強と
頭を悩ませる時間、そしておそらく悔しい思いをする時間が必要だ。それでも皆さんに、その不快感と向き合いながら
学び続ける中で生まれる疑問をしっかり探求してほしい。それが本当に学ぶ唯一の方法だから。ありがとう、
見てくれて。これはQuantum Computing in Practiceの第5話だった。次回はHamiltonianをゼロからシミュレートする方法を探っていく。
またすぐ会おう。